[Music]
today 86 of enterprises have more than a
quarter of their infrastructure in the
cloud and the rapid adoption of the
cloud is driving demand for
professionals with the right cloud
computing skill set
that's why there's been over 47 000
cloud architecture job postings in major
u.s markets in the past 12 months alone
and those roles are forecasted to grow
40 percent over the next two years
if you're a cloud developer devops
professional i.t infrastructure
professional or someone with adjacent
skill sets or interests our cloud
architect using microsoft azure
nanodegree program is a great
opportunity to meet that massive demand
in this program industry professionals
will teach you how to design and deploy
scalable efficient and resilient cloud
architecture with microsoft azure
you will execute a migration plan for
on-premise servers and databases to
azure
monitor cloud availability and simulate
and test failure scenarios and recovery
by the time you graduate from this
program you'll have a portfolio of three
job relevant projects that will
demonstrate your mastery of azure
deployments migration security and more
ready to bring your career to the cloud
sign up for udacity's cloud architect
using microsoft azure nanodegree program
today